hay algunas cosas que yo creo creo que
la familia es el modelo a seguir más
importante que tienen los niños
entendiéndose como familia cualquiera
sea el vínculo que se genera por la
convivencia creo que alimentarse bien
está directamente relacionado en la
mayoría de los casos con cocinar caseros
cocinar casero como una forma de tener
hábitos saludables pero también de dar
amor contención valores a través del
alimento según un estudio del ministerio
de salud pública en uruguay presenta una
de las cifras más altas de sobrepeso
obesidad de la región cuatro de cada
diez niños padecen sobrepeso u obesidad
y estas cifras cree que está en aumento
había que analizar los factores por los
cuales estamos cambiando hábitos
alimenticios hoy les voy a hablar de uno
de ellos el tiempo
creo también que el tiempo es una de las
mayores limitantes para cocinar en casa
en casa cuesta mucho administrarlos
porque todos tenemos poco tiempo vivimos
una vida muy acelerada y creo que
también el tiempo hay que saber
planificarlo hay que entender que hay
que optimizar para poder hacer algo tan
sencillo como cocinar
a partir de la historia de algunos
fragmentos de la historia de mi vida y
les quiero contar cómo me demostró la
vida que para mí el tiempo no debería de
ser una limitante
mi nombre es leticia sincero soy
ingeniera química mamá de tres y
cocinera es decir libertad en san jose y
nací en mi casa en mi casa porque a mi
madre no vivió el tiempo de llegar a un
sanatorio créanme que cuando mi madre me
dice que para ello no le dio el tiempo
es porque verdaderamente no le dio el
tiempo mamá tenía mis dos hermanos 24
años muy chicos mis dos hermanos yo
estaban la francisca padilla fallecía
unos meses antes de dar a luz así que
fue todo un revuelo en el mar yo siempre
me lo cuentan como una historia
divertida que encarnaban transportando
agua caliente para hacer de esa sala de
parto improvisada lo más seguro posible
y bueno tuvo un final feliz así que
finalmente es una historia divertida
para muchos de contar
en este contexto mi madre además del
factor emocional también tenía un factor
económico importante mi papá era
camionero y había comprado un camión
unos meses antes de morir lo cual en el
81 esa deuda se había hecho el triple
para mi madre que tenía que trabajar por
porte el triple porque el contexto
uruguayo el dólar subió mucho y bueno
eso se triplicó entonces la cuestión
escritor yo tenía que administrar su
tiempo con nosotros para trabajar para
limpiar y también para darnos amor
contención y saben también para que para
estudiar porque me sé en ese panorama mi
madre un día decide que nosotros éramos
chicos que quería terminar el liceo así
que se puso a ser quinto y sexto de
liceo mientras nosotros éramos chicos
y los recuerdos que tengo de esa
infancia es una infancia muy feliz en
donde de repente acompañan a mi madre a
una feria a manzanares subsistencias los
que se acuerdan eran un paseo en
cuestión el que nos divertíamos
llegábamos administrábamos todos
jugábamos de repente a los almacenes y
para mí esos son recuerdos que en donde
mi madre haciendo economía de hogar
no hacía parte de su rutina nos hacía
parte de su rutina también tengo
recuerdos con la comida como por ejemplo
el día del niño que no era el regalo del
día de niño era llegar a consumir esos
carritos caseros que nos había hecho mi
madre el día anterior que todos los días
del niño díaz de perritos caseros
independientemente de lo material
que era pasado a ser ya secundario
entonces en esta infancia feliz mi madre
la forma de organizarse y ahorrar que
tenía era esa una compra más a gran
escala para ahorrar y no vamos a detener
un poco para hablar de esta compra
semanal
una compra semanal que podemos hacer el
día que tenemos más tiempo estamos más
tranquilos y todos los días hacer
compras realmente nos quita tiempo y
hacer una compra semanal el día que
estamos con más tiempo nos va a ayudar
en primer lugar a comprar bastante
variados vamos a hacer una compra de
lácteos de carnes frutas verduras y ahí
ese día además de llegar con esa compra
le vamos a organizar y organizarla
significa también desinfectar lavar es
un buen momento para compensar los que
hay que desinfectar y lavar todos los
alimentos también es una forma de
adelantar pasos tengan unos limpios y yo
los tengo organizados en heladera que de
repente puede ayudarme porque estoy
trayendo dependiendo de la cantidad que
seamos una buena cantidad de cosas así
que hemos organizarme en mi ladera con
los buenos contenedores plásticos una
forma no suelo organizar el tiempo sino
también el espacio
y voy a adelantar pasos ese día para la
semana también puedo hacer otras cosas
que se las voy a ir contando más
adelante también entonces me críe con
este tipo de actividades en familia que
eran parte de nuestra rutina y que yo no
la sentía como una carga porque estaban
incorporadas
entonces después bueno adolescencia fui
a la facultad de elegir un a través de
la ingeniería química en donde si bien
me gustaba mucho la cocina quería hacer
una carrera universitaria y me uno en
ese momento que ya había terminado
elíseo decide también hacer facultad de
química sin que somos de la misma
generación que facultad de fomenta de
química
vino me recibí bueno después envejece un
máster a españa de ingestión de
adhesivos llegué acá empecé con un
empleo público a trabajar en un amplio
público como profesional y finalmente
llegó la maternidad la maternidad que
fue un momento en donde es todo esto que
yo creía lo tuve que poner en práctica y
ver qué pasaba con mi tiempo y bueno ahí
mi tiempo me di cuenta de que no estaba
tan bien destinado no estaba bien usado
porque el trabajo que yo tenía
me implicaba cuando después de tener mis
tres hijos muy seguidos y de terminar la
maternidad la lactancia y tener que ir a
completar mi horario completo me
implicaba
10 horas fuera de casa entonces mi
tiempo no estaba bien destinado ahí fue
un momento bastante particular en mi
carrera en donde tuve que tomar una
decisión y esa decisión fue dejar un
empleo público pese a todas las miradas
amenazantes con lo que implica dejar un
empleo público pero lo hice
empecé a pensar en dar clases de cocina
para niños y bueno en ese momento
aparece
como una posibilidad
decisión importante había que darle otro
giro a mi carrera profesional y además
vencer un montón de preconceptos que yo
tenía con lo que implicaba ser parte de
un reality me animé porque también una
de las ficciones que me había dado mi
madre era que nunca era tarde para hacer
lo que quería ya había empezado conmigo
facultad en la misma generación
pese a nada que tenía entonces
fue un momento muy crítico de mi carrera
donde bueno me tiré al agua me tiré
hacia esa piscina y jugué ese juego
ahora estoy donde quiero estar y
haciendo lo que me gusta hacer pero
tengo varios trabajos relacionados a la
química a la cocina y adoro realmente
este me hace muy feliz hacer lo que hago
pero tengo poco tiempo es una realidad
como todos como muchos de nosotros y lo
trato de administrar ese tiempo otra de
las formas indeseable de la compra
semanal bueno como cómo podemos hacer de
otra manera también para administrar el
tiempo ayudarnos con ayudas que le llamo
yo una de las ayudas les dije una
heladera bien organizada a la compra
limpia también podemos pensar entrenar
distintos algún electrodoméstico en los
distintos no un electrodoméstico que les
ayude ese día en la compra semanal que
tenemos más tiempo llegada bien enviar
pero además podemos picar por ejemplo se
llamó ron
y administrarla distribuirla en
distintas porciones obviamente que va a
depender también de las costumbres de
cada uno de lo que cada uno le guste
comer sí pero por ejemplo para tener
pronto para un sofrito hizo lo que
ustedes tiene acostumbrados a consumir
esas porciones las vamos a guardar si
son para ese día siguiendo en la era
pero también pueden ser para el freezer
si las vamos a consumir después de unos
días si nos ayudamos el día que estamos
con más tiempo todo este tipo de tareas
también puede ser por ejemplo una tarde
una carne la podemos posicionar como por
ejemplo por un guiso sin tenerlas
congeladas y vamos a usar más días o
limpiar otra pieza un pollo
estos son determinadas ayudas que nos
que nos sirven este a la hora de
adelantar casos que van a pasar ese día
qué va a pasar el día que estamos
apurados que venimos de trabajar
cansados con todos esos pasos que
tenemos adelantados bueno decidir qué
hacer de comer con una heladera con un
montón de ayudas es mucho más sencillo
que decidir qué hacer que convenimos
supermercado el universo de productos
que tenemos en un supermercado es enorme
es muy difícil además de ir todos los
días que ya nos quita tiempo la llena
con cristales supermercado cualquier
establecimiento
haber hecho una sola compra nos resume
el que voy a hacer de comer algo que hay
en vuestra
y eso es infinitamente más fácil
vemos ahora las ventajas además de
obviamente decidir más fácil de hacer
recorrer las ventajas de este método
voy a comprar variado porque al haber
hecho una compra en donde visualice todo
lo que compre voy a comprar variada de
frutas de verduras no repito no vuelve
con la repetición por derrepente y
muchas veces sino acordarme de lo que
había consumido un lunes y viernes no
acordarme lo que había consumido ni los
pulmones por ejemplo voy a comprar
rallado además obviamente cocinar casero
implica también conocer lo que agregó
cuánta sal cuánto azúcar agregó y cuánta
grasa griego estoy controlando lo que
consume cuando tenemos niños incluir a
los niños dentro de nuestras rutinas es
muy valioso porque si el tiempo es poco
organizarlo con ellos para ello se torna
una actividad en familia y pasa a ser un
juego pasa a ser un momento que
compartimos además también hablando de
los niños el concepto para ellos el
alimento es otro aprenden a comer
aprenden los sabores de las cosas
conocen mucho mejor los alimentos
también evitamos consumir ultra
procesados yo no digo que sea algo que
me comprara fuera lo podemos hacer pues
que no lo podamos hacer está bien hay
que mover la economía podemos comprar en
otros lados pero la comida casera tiene
otro valor eso lo tenemos que usar sí
pero como recurso y no como un hábito lo
mismo que los alimentos ultra procesados
no está bien que un niño interprete que
un lácteo es un postrecito que viene en
determinado imagen y que ese es el
concepto del activa del niño una comida
casera por ejemplo un lácteo casero una
crema que puede ser con muy litro de
leche que voy a ahorrar que voy a saber
cuánta azúcar le estoy poniendo que
puedo distribuirla en varios carritos
para varios días de la merienda así
alternando
el concepto para un niño de ese alimento
es que el lácteo puede ser otra cosa
entonces el mensaje que les estamos
dejando otros valores a través de la
comida casera entonces volvamos otra vez
al principio de la charla creo que la
falta de tiempo hay que ayudarla creo
que tenemos que saber administrarlo para
ser viable algo que creemos que es
inviable
creo que cocinar en casa no es solamente
todas las ventajas que les comenté que
son muchas de además de los hábitos
alimenticios
creo que cocinar en casa es dar amor a
través de un plato de comida